welcome to this video playing endless
fighter again this is not helpful for
getting my rating up this guy is really
a good player okay he played f4 so we
have a Dutch defense reversed 93 William
maybe okay let's just let's just occupy
the center hmm not sure that I
understand the point of this setup
really what does he doing at the end is
playing deform okay let's let's try to
complete development here G 493
something like that maybe yeah I can
play a move like f5 I mean so that's
very mmm yeah come on it's just prevent
g for me it's not necessary but at the
same time it's not bad yeah I am this
was my suspicions that he needs to do
that to prevent the five but this is
just comfortable now God Bishop a six
and term is just slightly better for
black of the position
nothing dramatic but I'm comfortable the
night is traveling to d6
just just here well why not mmm night f2
is not leading to anything right yeah
not really what about g5 is this a this
premature maybe can take twice platform
now so so this looks like a very very
nice position what to do Bishop to d3
maybe get this and then see form we are
not clear in are many ways to obtain a
good position
maybe you can attack it I guess I'm
night you won or something but yeah
that's not bad the question is I could
also play on the Kings side maybe this
was better I don't know he has weakened
himself on the kingside a bit it was a
possibility just was g5 preparing g5
maybe this was was even better it's
possible yeah what now you can still
play g5 oh come on and I need to catch
up on the clock a bit does not help if
i'll play completely like it's happening
at the moment and at the end child was
on time yeah I lose to lose a piece yeah
the moment you say his outplayed okay
cannot he cannot he couldn't take it
because of f3 but yeah still it wasn't
necessary to to to to overlook 26 it's
still pretty good I think mmm yeah again
look here
I'll switch the night over I'm yeah yeah
without the night I don't make any any
headway in this position and still I
should I should calculate a variation
once in a while it's just dashing out
those instant moves and it does not the
rook does not have a good square at the
moment yeah I can give this check here
first so that Jackie needs to retreat
what about bishop age 6 cm g5s night f5
yeah probably yeah I thought I still
think why this is bad here I mean he's
got bad pieces everywhere bishop on g2
91-93 maybe you can move the Queen now
and allow the gym at the time I'm a
threatening mate ok so this one I still
if I'm playing 93 I can also take here
mmm yeah it's still slightly tricky
the clock I'm simply calculating not
fast enough sometimes and take cm and
there should be three and Bishop f4
should win I hope take see I take III
are up general g8 stronger ook g8 why it
is completely completely busted just 40
seconds is the problem
take 0 PG idea this is really winning
give a player this one this one here
okay yeah I'm not meeting here probably
to any way to continue the mating attack
guess not yeah this is this is er the
end game is also excellent but I does
not have work everyone excellent the
scooter it's just just just a flat-out
win but the time now yes no moves maybe
I can even manage that in 20 seconds the
night is dominated it's very important
time warning check
check
check check check check yeah I manage
checkmate well yeah it's always tricky
if you spent so much time even if even
if it's a total win ma'am yeah really
blunder t6 it didn't really matter so
much it seems it was just just good
anyway but it's not necessary at all I
can just go here for example and why
this it's just toast here look at the
pieces there they're all dead all dead
pieces and I can I just don't need to
give it up but I worked ever look this
simply he cannot take really because of
f3 this is this is too much on the
capture both so he needs to retreat and
this is still not clear because because
of the the big difference in the piece
activity we are f5 I didn't really
appreciate but it it was ok check and
this is a winner g5 night at five I
probably have something better yeah look
g8 is even stronger minus 14 this is
quite quite a lot yeah but ok I was glad
to have seen one win and I think this
wins yeah this is minus 6 and here Rock
g8 is even stronger yeah okay yeah rook
g8 of course yeah
yeah this makes life much easier if you
play those moves Luke g8 this is just
the winning end game I guess yeah it's
it's completely completely winning
because of the points but 20 seconds
it's just easier with rupes Luke GA to
play for a check made and here he's
completely paralyzed with the night this
is why it is so so relatively easy to
win jack now it's the night is just gone
Brooke f2 is made even yeah Luke f2 is
even a mate it's quite check this is
quite quite nice cannot prevent the maid
now or only with this kind of slow moves
and made into ok and this this was just
dramatic because of the 14 the 14
seconds yeah yeah the whole opening set
up was a bit weird bye bye him I mean f
five assists a slightly strange move I
know but I just wanted to prevent his
idea with g4 and I mean he only black
can be better because of my my better
piece activity this is just just a
better piece than this end I have this
idea I'm quicker on the crucial squares
and he never played 95 for example which
I found surprising ok thanks for
watching